everyone in the shop came to watch every
time that Bruce get suited up everyone
comes out stairs that's when it started
getting special way for us
way more than you last fitting
this is ambitious it looks cool if it
works like everything we want it to it's
cool I've got to make that work we're
going to Comic Con
when you have Alan Scott come out and go
you know all the faces of these guys who
have done it for 30 years alternate to
12 year olds the ultimate thrill comes
when you get to see it come to life it's
come full circle
what started as a seed and great ideas
in your head now you're performing and
that's the great joy that we all have I
think that there's going to be constant
attention where it's setup and word of
mouth is gonna spread very quickly I
think that's just gonna be a lot of
people are going to check this thing out
a lot of people are gonna back away from
the thing just because it looks like
it's made out of tons of steel and it's
just lightweight plastic you know when
you're when you're looking at it you
just kind of go alright well there it is
you know and then then he sort of like
jumps at you it was pretty startling you
know I even jumped a little bit I think
the fans will love it you know it's just
to see something that big that details
that cool walking around is gonna be
really fun I've always very impressed
with the cosplay or people who get
dressed up because that's a lot of work
it's very very impressive so I think
that they will be very very very happy
to see something so massive and for them
that really is built just for them you
know to enjoy and have something to
interact with that is the crowd you want
to unveil in front of both people love
the fantastic and the side pie and they
love cosplay this will be definitely the
most interactive character that I've
dealt with in the comic-con situation
which is really cool and you know it's
going to create a huge buzz I think so a
lot of people are going to start talking
about it when he's performing live I
love the noise and sound effects and
everything get added in post so this is
actually happening a real time and it
just makes the character come to life
but if something's actually moving and
making noises and interacting with them
I think it's going to blow the parts
great
test how many seconds do I have to
comply how many seconds do I have to
reach minimum safe distance
Wow you see this guy come out like a guy
who's here a rope I know it's a guy does
the guy use the guy disappears so this
machine steps up and he starts kind of
moving his arms that's really fluid this
is amazing and he he starts to walk and
he's not stumbling right this is that
first moment I think my most memorable
moment was when we got kicked out of
Comic Con I mean how many people have
gotten kicked out of comic-con because I
don't have badges it's like you never
get in in the first place we not only
got in we got in with a giant crew with
a film crew with gigantic you know 400
pounds robot
I must memorable because it was
stressful as hell was when Bruce was in
the NBC and we had to take him to a
whole nother location which was probably
three-quarters of a block away you could
see everybody just coming across the
street and I could just see nothing but
bobbing heads and it was crazy if we I
did feel like we were rock stars at that
time there were moments where like oh
this would be fun oh this would be fun
I'm like Bruce is in there you're
burning him it's like quick just make
your decision just go go go go go this
is your fruit where's your
all right guys is the last photo right
now last photo that's it thank you all
thank you very much people that go to
comic-con they all have a very similar
goal and that is to shine and share and
see all their shared geekdom it's an
ideal place to take a character like
this every one of your senses is engaged
when you're standing in front of
something real like this you can see it
you can hear it you can touch it it
really made people respond
people actually thought there was a
robot which is kind of fun even in
person it fooled a lot of people which
was really cool and everybody just
wanted it to like be amazed at how cool
it was probably the most exciting thing
I take away from this week was we were
welcome to show off this artistry
everything that you're working toward is
when you're live on camera in front of
people and you get to react and interact
with them and make them smile and you
know make them look at it and wonder you
know what the hell is that how is that
working it's so satisfying that's that's
the ultimate thing is to like take it
out there and show people stuff that
they've never seen before
so in the end he was revealed did we
achieve the mission did we did we hit
the goal we were setting on to hit and
the answer is way beyond any marks